c'est quoi comme études matt bep bac pro
pop star comme études au fait aulas au
alors j'ai étudié à l'école à l'école
ah non pas d'en bas dans la wii vient
habiter jusqu'à quelle classe et bien
j'étais à côté de quelqu'un vous est
demandé j'ai un coeur d'or estacades
cette année non mais je suis parti très
tôt de l'école parce que l de la rue je
me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
pour moi et vice versa mais bien après
différemment et amusez-vous a été
jusqu'à quelle classe j'ai oublié je
dirais troisième pas loin loin de la
troisième peut-être non un ca fait un
petit ça paie quand même n'ont même pas
de sa lenteur aucun concours lycée n'est
pas des concours qui s'est dit c'est
qu'elle classait troisième nom ou un
truc comme ça
voilà c'est quoi la voyante elle va
arriver là tout de suite elle va te dire
ah ouais c'est ça que je sais faire à
dernier à dernier extrait ces dons c'est
mon choix il ya une émission
s'intéresser à la drague sur internet
j'avais déjà dragué sur internet sur
caramail à l'époque
ah ouais tu l'avais fait aussi ouais
mais y'avait pas de photo de profil donc
c'est toujours un peu déceptif passé
alors eh ben elle cherche il a mûri
internet on a eu le témoignage de karine
elle pensait avoir trouvé le prince
charmant
sauf qu'au moment de la rencontre elle a
eu une petite mauvaise surprise enfin
une grosse surprise
je vous êtes allé sur internet pour
rencontrer un homme m'amuser à la base
pour vous amuser vous rencontrez un
homme vous aviez vu la photo plusieurs
photos il était séduisant très séduisant
vous finissez par vous donner rendez
vous au bout de cinq semaines on s'est
rencontré et là en fait je vais chercher
à la gare et ressemble aux photos il
était grand métis beau enfin tout pour
lui quoi je lui demande s'il a passé un
bon voyage
il me regarde et me sourit en fait il
restait plus que deux dans la mousse
quand marie avec dedans on va bien sûr
non mais c'est vrai tu as tout si cholet
cannes cannes bien les dents ça sera
fait avec ce que vous avez déjà eu une
mauvaise surprise ou quoi pas tout le
temps tout le temps on ignore c'est pour
les personnes la mauvaise surprise oui
c'est ça mais on a fait une vraie
différence entre la photo wenn la
personne que tu vois en vrai elle a
plein marmaille anna n'en parle ce soir
ouais vous voulez ça s'appelait comment
mariana et aliens
ouais j'ai lu une fois on s'est vus deux
fois et finalement ça n'a jamais eu lieu
et des mario brésilien mon problème
c'est que ce n'est pas d'hier n'ont donc
j'ai accepté le deuxième rendez vous
j'ai accepté troisième rendez-vous et
après j'ai fait je suis absent je suis
perdu je ne suis plus là mais quand vous
vous attaquez mode fait bill dernière
que je parle beaucoup avec les mains
vous avez déjà craqué sur internet sur
les réseaux web on ne croit pas que
moi-même
ah ouais si on vous au téléphone il faut
appeler après mais j'ai des potes en
fait qu utilisent main solidaire seul
salon identité pour le faire ah oui
ouais donc après vous rencontrer des
personnes non se font passer pour moi
ces profils mon profil et des fluides
comme ils connaissent à peu toutes mes
intonations comment charles et wissam al
samarrai partir
[Applaudissements]